[Music]
social study what the stars are posting
online Kim Zolciak goes on a Twitter
rant about her experience at an airport
in Germany according to Kim her bags
were searched for being American and
says they were quote throwing my wigs
around and after finally making it to
the gate Kim was apparently told she
needed to go back through security again
well I said this was crazy he replied no
it's because of your government other
celebs abroad Bella Hadid going bikini
clad with her pals in Jamaica chrissy
teigen and john legend are on vacation
in morocco with daughter luna who
learned a new word what is that Cat Cat
Cat
then there's behati prinsloo sharing a
photo of matching anklets she got with
her and Adam Levine's daughter dusty
rose the day before she celebrated Adams
38th birthday with several silly snaps
of her hubby and last but not least
hayden panettiere shares a sweet photo
holding her daughter kaia tight with the
caption best feeling in the whole wide
world
[Music]